- Is it true that you built,
cause I love, I'm a Trekky,
like, next generation, like
John Luke Picard, Worf,
- [Seth] Sure, sure.
- I love star Trek so much.
And I heard that you built a
replica when you were a kid of,
did you do The Enterprise?
- I did, you know, my
sister went off to Japan
as an exchange student
and her room was vacant
for the summer.
So I was like, oh, this
would be kind of fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah, I think I've built
the, built the, what?
She went to Japan.
- She got to go to Japan?
- [Seth] Yeah she did!
- Did you get to do anything like that?
- I didn't. I didn't. I would love,
I still have never, that's one place
I've never been is Japan. I'd love to go.
- I Love Japan.
- Yeah, yeah.
- The temples are really cool.
- Yeah. People love it.
- Cause the city's so crowded
but you get to the temples
and it's like so beautiful.
- [Seth] Yeah.
And the cell phones are
like the size of like, you
know, they're like that big.
- [Kelly] They're like, oh
- It's like the future.
- I love that.
- [Seth] Yeah.
- I love anything that's interesting.
- I dunno know somebody, somebody told me,
I don't know if that's true.
- Oh. I was like, I don't
remember the cell phone moment
but maybe you'll have yours.
(Seth laughs)
No, but I love that you built it.
Was it like cardboard?
Or like you built it--
- Like, yeah, it was like
cardboard and Christmas lights.
- Love. Well, who was
your favorite character?
Like, Lieutenant Riker? I know them all.
- My favorite, you know--
- Geordi La forge, rainbow guy
- I loved them all. Jonathan Frakes
is the best guy to have a beer with.
I'll tell you that.
- Okay. Okay.
I wouldn't know that, but I'm
gonna take your word on that.
- [Seth] Highly recommend it.
- Okay. Sounds like a fun time,
or maybe one that I might be scared of.